what's up guys bang bang this week in
Bitcoin was a weird one Bitcoin itself
just going sideways and being pretty
boring honestly but there's lots of
other things around Bitcoin that are
worth paying attention to the first is a
continued Fallout from FTX and Sam
Beckman freed with news breaking just
yesterday that Sam Beckman freed was
extending loans via some of his entities
to the former CEO of the block and none
of the staffers at the Block knew it's
mass chaos and we continue to see the
tentacles of SBF and FTX reaching
throughout the entire industry the
second thing though is that we continue
to watch the macro environment put
Bitcoin in that sideways trajectory the
macro economy over the last year has
frankly sucked the Federal Reserve has
done a fantastic job of destroying
investor demand and as they have done
that by creating those tighter Financial
conditions more and more people are
wondering when will the FED pivot and
how exactly is that going to go down
well this upcoming week we are going
going to get another interest rate
decision Elon Musk one of the richest
people in the world and now the proud
owner of twitter.com saying that he
believes that a raise in interest rates
will only put more pressure and a higher
likelihood on a painful recession in
2023 I tend to agree with him but we
will see what the FED decides to do and
last but not least all the way in Ghana
there was a Bitcoin conference this past
week CEO of square Jack Dorsey now known
as block he went on a tour of a couple
of different countries and went in Kenya
he tweeted out this photo of the
hydroelectric powered Bitcoin mining
facility this is a great example of what
anyone in the world with an internet
connection some Ingenuity some desire
for Innovation and an interest in the
Bitcoin Network can accomplish Bitcoin
is a decentralized network that has a
persistent demand for energy and
computational power and so we are just
beginning to understand what is actually
possible and it continues to to feed in
to the creation of the most secure
Computing Network in the world keep your
eyes on the FED decision and remember
that although price continues to go
sideways there is tons and tons and tons
of building going on in the industry and
ultimately when we get back to better
times that building will pay off hope
you guys enjoy these weekly updates on
bitcoin and the broader Market I will
see all of you next Saturday